okay so i'm a person that absolutely
loves mega events in comic books ever
since i started collecting them i've
been someone who has to pick up all the
side stories offshoots and companions
because it adds so much to the overall
storyline in my opinion civil war is
actually my favorite series of all time
because the unique points of views and
perspectives that happened at the
characters really helped to enrich in
and tell this overarching narrative the
end feels all are better for it because
you know the journey that the heroes and
villains have gone on and what it took
to get to that point now this to me is
the reason why the mcu infinity saga
works so well and all of the origin
stories side chapters and post-credits
scenes culminated in avengers end game
which i feel is the most ambitious
crossover ever since archie versus the
predator
now in the movie is a standout moment
that gives me goosebumps every time and
it's a scene that had audiences in the
theater going
[Applause]
well not me because it's heavy spoilers
and i was the guy doing this
but why does the scene work so well and
why is it something that hits home every
single time that we watch it well that's
what we're going to be breaking down in
this video and if you love it 3 000 then
make sure you smash the thumbs up button
we do videos on our favorite film
moments every single week and if you
think we're worthy to be in your
subscription feed then we'd absolutely
love it if you hit that button too if
this is your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man now let's get
into why this scene in avengers end game
is absolutely perfect
okay so mania is an item in the marvel
universe that no mere mortal can wield
ever since its first appearance in
2011's thor it's been held in high
regard due to those only deemed worthy
being able to lift it did it work
throughout the saga it's been something
that's aided the god of thunder on his
many adventures but in the main timeline
the item was destroyed by thor's sister
heller
because of this he had to go through his
own redemption arc in both ragnarok and
in infinity war in which he gained
stormbreaker and doomed the universe to
death
you should have gone for the head
cheers mate however upon journeying back
in time thor ended up taking malniere
which not only showed that he was still
worthy but it also set the pieces in
place for us to see that cap was too now
steve is a character that very much
represents the best of what humanity can
be
i could do this all day when we met him
in the first avenger he was someone who
showed us that though we might not have
physical strength our will can go a long
way and it's what's inside that counts
now not all of us can end up getting the
super soldier serum but stories like
episode 1 of what if showed that no
matter what because of his character
steve was always destined to be a hero
one of the reasons that him wielding the
hammer works so well is because it very
much bridges the gap between man and god
and shows us first hand that we have the
power within ourselves to achieve that
status after all many of the gods that
we've seen in the mcu are what you would
call petty and squabbling self-centered
sociopaths and steve rogers lifting this
cements that we can be better than the
ones that rule us but it's not just that
that makes the scene pop off and i doubt
many of you even considered it when
watching it fly into cap's hand what we
love about this scene is that it
actually shows something that we all
suspected since age of ultron and that
is that steve rogers is worthy him
unleashing this feels like a payoff 10
years in the making and it makes cap one
of the top characters in the marvel
universe however the build up to it is
also deeply layered in specific
iconography and it also mirrors the
scene in infinity war which makes the
moment hit home even harder in that we
watched as thor drove stormbreaker into
thanos's chest instead of his head
because of this the villain was able to
carry out the snap which destroyed half
of all life in the universe and left the
world in a state of grief for five
solitary years the first hour of endgame
very much dealt with this morning and
though the heroes managed to kill thanos
early on they still ended up as a loss
and in no better of a position than
they'd been at the end of the snap
though this opening act was slow paced
it was important to have this room to
breathe after the almost non-stop action
that infinity war was and it showed our
heroes all coping with loss in lots of
different ways that's why ant-man's
return was so powerful as it offered a
glimmer of hope in a desolate and bleak
future that allowed the heroes to get
back what they'd once lost we watched as
the avengers went back in time to
collect the infinity stones but in doing
so they ushered forth a worse version of
thanos who was now hell-bent on
destroying all life thanos journeyed to
the present and knowing that he was out
to destroy everyone this time the stakes
felt infinitely higher i think it's safe
to say that he smashed tony cap and thor
like you should smash that like button
and watching the three most popular
avengers getting the crap kicked out of
them made you realize how low humanity's
chances were i can't overstate how much
thanos whoops their ass i reminded me of
that time stone cold showed up and just
started stunning everyone just look at
the guy just stuttering everyone
non-stop stone cold steve stop
stuttering everyone please
let the lads live now left with just
thor thanos completely wails on him and
when the former calls stormbreaker to
his hand thanos catches it mid-air and
starts to drive it into his chest this
is a reverse to how things were at the
end of infinity war and just as it seems
like thor is about to have a heart to
heart with storm breaker we get one of
the biggest saves since stone cold steve
austin saved the wwf from the wcw
goddamn king look at him oh my god now
the hammer goes to cap's hand and he
catches it showing the shield in all its
glory before facing down against thanos
to take him head on this actually
capitalizes on a trope in tv and film
known as deus ex machina and in case you
don't know this translates to mean god
from the machine it's typically used to
describe a character just appearing out
of nowhere to say one that's in great
peril and it's appeared in lots of
movies and shows the worst version i can
think of is when the t-rex just
completely shows up out of nowhere
without making a noise at the end of
jurassic park
i say worst but yeah i do like this
moment to be fair and there is a reason
that this has become a trope because it
works so well in dramatic scenes why it
feels way better here though and more
than just a cheap gimmick is because it
combines several elements in order to
pull off a big reveal that builds upon
the past of the mcu and adds to cap's
character as a whole not only are we
seeing something that was teased all the
way back in age of ultron but we're also
witnessing caps step up to the next
level in order to go toe-to-toe with the
most powerful being in the universe cap
holding back thanos's hand in infinity
war came as a huge shock to the mad
titan and this builds upon that to show
that not only can he go toe-to-toe with
him but that he can also put him on the
back foot watching him summon forth
lightning and throw his hammer off the
shield so that it knocks thanos off
balance is absolutely incredible and i
love the way that cap swings it around
before hitting him in his ball sack of a
chin it's the first time in the fight
that you really feel that the heroes
have a chance and as ivan vonko said if
you can make god bleed people will cease
to believe in him this was something
that was shown in infinity war when tony
went head to head with him and even
though he threw everything he had at him
just for a drop of blood it did cement
that it was possible to beat him though
it's not highlighted in this fight we
also see that steve has managed to cut
thanos in a similar place and it truly
highlights what's to come the scene is
followed by the incredible avengers
assemble moment and the payoff of this
wouldn't work as well as it did without
the setup here in which we see one man
that symbolizes the best of us standing
against evil the scene works because not
only does it show us that those with the
strongest wills can stand against a god
but it also highlights the journey that
cab has gone on to get to this point
he's a character that was deemed as
someone who wasn't even worthy to join
the fight when he first started but now
he's leading the front line against the
ultimate force of destruction in the
entire universe it shows that the gap
between god and man has grown
significantly shorter and that we too
are worthy to stand amongst them if we
are pure of heart him being arguably the
most human character of us all makes us
get behind him and i feel like it's us
hitting thanos just as much as he is
it's an amazing moment that rightly made
people cheer in the cinema upon seeing
it for the first time and it's a scene
that i go back to time and time again to
remind me why i fell in love with the
mcu i can't overstate how much i get
chills every time i watch this and it
symbolizes that within us all there's a
hidden greatness that can come out at
any moment cap was there when we most
needed him and this scene is the perfect
culmination of his story and the
infinity saga as a whole it's a moment
for me that stands toe-to-toe with some
of the best in cinema and i feel that
it's absolutely perfect now obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on this
scene and if you agree with me or not
avengers end game is filled with about
well 50 moments like this so i'm sure
i'll note i'll be back to talk about the
film again in the future at some point
so let me know below what you want to
see next time just to let you know we
are in competition right now and giving
away three copies of the zack snyder dc
trilogy on the 30th of september all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the moment we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one on screen right
now so that's you then message me on
twitter heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
perfect scene in x-men first class we
pointed out why we absolutely love the
coin moment and all the build-up to it
that makes it really impactful if not
then thank you for singing through this
video i've been paul you've been the
best and i hope to see on the next one
take care peace